là où ça bouge nous sommes au panta
théâtre de caen pour la fin du site sur
les écritures contemporaines consacré à
la suisse dramaturgie suisse ce sera
samedi 21 mai bertrand tu peux aller
vers l'affiché de te plait merci on te
trompe d'ennemi tu ne fait que
participer à l'édification de bouc
émissaire et la cje top sous la mise en
scène de maya bosch
ce troisième volet part de la montée des
populismes en europe et notamment en
suisse
je bois du vin je bois de la bière je
m'exprime en public
je lis ce que je veux et puis au sein du
couple
j'ai mon mot à dire sur notre
procréation on a le sentiment que vous
disiez que l'actualité revient un petit
peu sur elle-même revient en arrière
avec cette montée des extrémismes peu
partout en europe
bah moi je suis la première à tomber par
terre quand je vois à quel point ça peut
être être gré de gpj crois même pas en
fait quand on est obligé dans le coup
c'est un obligé de faire avec ces
cellules tel qu'il est et puis en même
temps un niveau de culture et de
sophistication qui est très élevé en
même temps doit faire face à des
discours qui sont terrifiants de bêtise
de son arriéré coup parce que mon
travail est un travail d'expression
d'interrogation de recherche de
confrontation de différents discours
pour tout cela il me tue ils viennent le
tuer en suisse est ce qu'une pièce peut
changer quelque chose
moi je sais pas j'ai pas la prétention
que j'ai pas la prétention que cette
heure change vous sentez quoi dans la
peau du colibri
certainement que mon ambition c'est
quand même de déplacer un petit peu leur
point de vue de secouer le skweee de la
boîte crânienne de chacun de ce que les
émotions de chacun et qui ressortent un
petit peu différente comment il se
montrer ça oui j'ai cette ambition là
très fort bien se rendre compte que le
théâtre c'est un moyen qui artisanale
c'est pas une industrie à quoi ça sert
décrire ça je ne fais que dire mes peurs
profondes les exprimer les pressées à
froid on ne s'en sortira que si chacun
s'observe au plus vrai il faut tout dire
le travail des dramaturgies suisse sera
présenté au panta théâtre samedi à
partir de 19h
la 21e nuit du blues c'est au zénith de
caen vendredi avec notamment bernard
allison dès 20h à ne pas manquer
évidemment
là où ça bouge nous sommes à quant aux
ateliers intermédiaire pour vous
présenter la nouvelle pièce de la
compagnie grupo qui s'appelle alors view
a kill you musica troisième c'est tout
tu ne pouvais même pas approché de moi
sans souffrir
il n'y avait que de me tuer qui tu
aurais fait du bien alors tu es devenu
un criminel sans emploi c'est tout à
fait idiot la musica troisième c'est un
clin d'oeil à marguerite duras quelques
rats qui a écrit la musique à 65 qu'il a
réécrit en 85 et c'est en partant de ces
deux livres là où elle questionnait
beaucoup lecteurs sur le je t'aime je te
tue on est parti à quoi vous en avez
écrit un troisième à l'âme à la manière
de continuer l'histoire alors ceni
continue l'histoire c'est lié à la
manière de serre poser les questions et
problématiques triturer son texte le
fouiller rendre les interrogations
trente ans après trente ans après et les
voir ce que ça raconte aujourd'hui
michel voilà trois ans que je ne sais
rien de toi je ne sais même pas où tu
habites je ne sais rien rien du tout ce
que tu fais ce que tu vis avec qui c'est
le point à la virgule près et puis le
titre le dit c'est la musique a donc
c'est une histoire de son de rythmes
cette recherche dans le mot cette
recherche dans le corps aussi lorsqu'on
ne dit pas duras comme on dit du
shakespeare
il fallait bien que je fasse vite pour
rattraper le temps perdu perdu à
t'attendre perdu à nous regarder nous
disloqué
ça s'appelle donc iloveyou à kill you
musica troisième c'est aux ateliers
intermédiaire à côté
tribunal sur la presqu'île de caen etc à
14h30 et à 19h30 le vendredi 20 mai et
voilà vous savez tout